der nachwuchs der grüne der steht jetzt
bereit der bundesvorstand vor denen der
ju von den jungen grünen wurde neu
gewählt zwei junge menschen 20 und 25
jahre alt man sollte denken weltoffen
doch wenn man sich genauer anschaut
welche äußerungen in der jüngsten und
auch älteren vergangenheit so gefallen
sind dann muss man da das weltoffene
schon ganz schön großes fragezeichen
setzen ja absolut also die grüne jugend
ist ja gibt sich ja als das weltoffene
was ist nur gibt man kämpft wirklich
gegen jede form der diskriminierung aber
man kämpft halt auch sehr sehr ruppig
mit dem politischen gegner
beziehungsweise politischen ex gegner
denn jetzt möchte man mit der fdp
koalieren und wenn man sich anschaut was
der neue chef der grünen jugend der herr
dinos die man da auch im hintergrund bei
uns bei uns sieht aber das ist die
chefin ganz gut allende heinrich die
wurde gestern auch gewählt dies durch
etwas andere äußerungen aufgefallen
durch sehr sehr zum teil streitbare zum
teil wirklich absurde auch
menschenfeindliche treats gute kann man
sagen da war sie 14 jahre alt in dieser
debatte möchte ich jetzt auch gar nicht
reingehen das was wirklich brisant ist
für die koalition ist eben ihr co
sprecher das ist der herr kinos den man
hier sieht der durchaus als
radikalinskis sich einen namen gemacht
hat deswegen wurde er glaube ich auch
gewählt und der hat wenn man sich seine
tweets anschaut in den letzten jahren
fast nichts anderes gemacht als
christian lindner zu beschimpfen als
gelbe 0 als rechter kotzbrocken da hört
man ja auch den den ton das ist ja
offenbar der politische stil für den man
bei der grünen jugend zum vorsitzenden
gewählt wird
das hat er glaube ich getwittert nachdem
die afd mit hilfe von stimmen der fdp in
thüringen käme recht genau wer gewählt
umgekehrt die fdp wurde gewählt mit
hilfe von stimmen der afd linden hat
sich damals sehr klar verhalten sich
schnell distanziert da wurde alles
rückgängig gemacht für die grüne jugend
ist es aber völlig okay leute ins amt zu
wählen die sich so über politische
gegner äußern überhaupt ist dieser junge
mann aufgefallen mit sehr radikalen
äußerungen mit enteignungs forderung
also der politische stil der da an den
tag gelegt wird
um die politische konkurrenz zu
kritisieren möglich also dass das
eigentlich das letzte was man sich unter
demokraten vorstellt ist das jetzt total
unwichtig weil das eben irgend ein
junger politiker gesagt hat oder spielt
die grüne jugend durchaus eine rolle so
ricarda lang beispielsweise sitzen mit
am tisch bei den koalitionsverhandlungen
und meines wissens nach haben die ja
auch eine gewisse rolle in allen
vorstandssitzungen dabei in allen
wichtigen entscheidungen zumindest
integriert bei den grünen absoluter so
gestern hat die gesamte grünen-spitze
diesen beiden neuen chefs gratuliert und
in tolle arbeit und auch eine tolle
zusammenarbeit gewünscht und da frage
ich mich wie will man eigentlich die
neuen koalitionsgespräche mit diesen
leuten an der seite durchbringen das ist
für die grünen natürlich ein
riesenproblem dass annalena baerbock und
robert habeck erfolgreich die
verhandlung zu ende führen möchten ist
ja klar aber die müssen das was sie da
verhandeln und auch mit wem sie da
verhandeln irgendwie ihren eigenen
leuten verkauf koalitionsvertrag mit dem
rechten kotzbrocken richtig mit der
gelben 0 und dem rechten koalitions dem
rechten koalitionskurs nichts über uns
konz brocken
das muss die grüne jugend ja mit
absegnen und entweder machen die so wie
es ganz viele in der politik machen das
was ich gestern gesagt habe interessiert
mich heute nicht mehr oder sie bleiben
dabei und dann will ich wissen wie man
eine koalition mit einem finanzminister
lindner mit leuten wie wolfgang kubicki
also leute wie das absolute feindbild
sind für die grüne jugend der eigenen
basis verkommt
[Musik]